[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum boy do i love that
you're tuned in and you're listening and
if you're here for gate and monterrazzo
i thank you but if you like the
interview i asked you to stick around i
ask you to maybe subscribe to the
podcast uh stick with us i think you'll
learn something i hope you like it write
a review it really would mean a lot to
me uh even if you don't know me for [ __ ]
and you know gayten
right ryan right yeah that's that's what
it's about it's about support and if you
like something maybe listen to it that's
all i'm saying oh yeah that's a big deal
did you have a good week i had a good
week
right now i think we're a little bit on
uh not on edge but we're still excited
because uh we just did an interview with
judd apatow and it was just fantastic
which will air down the road and it was
just uh we were both kind of like just
so excited he was such an influence on
on both of our lives and the movies that
he created and
it was just special wasn't it yeah i'm
still i'm still processing it because i
know you are because it's one of those
people who's just sort of out there like
making stuff and then
you never think oh i'm never going to
sit in the same room as that dude no
here we are well maybe you will you just
did we just did you just did uh i'd love
for you to follow us on our handles on
our social media handles at insideapod
on twitter at insideviewpodcast on
instagram and facebook write a review
message us um we also have the inside of
you online store you can get smallville
signed lunchboxes from me or me and
welling
you can get autographed pictures of lex
or inside of you mugs inside of you
tumblers
so many cool things uh also
the band my band sunspin is playing
march 5th it's that's the saturday is
that what march 5th is
on your phone march 5th
uh we are playing two shows right two
shows saturday 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time we play covers we play
originals it's a lot of fun there's
prizes there's zooms please show up just
go to sunspin.com look for the link that
takes you to stage it or go to
stageit.com and type in sunspin
you can also get a zoom with us on
sunspin.com and i really it means a lot
and also lastly if you want to join
patreon patrons save the show they
really give back to the show so if you
enjoy it you want to give something back
go to patreon.com inside of you that's
patreon.com inside of you and uh there's
different uh what do you call them tears
tears um and uh
anyway that's really all i have to say
i'm i'm very excited i think the show
we've been getting some great guest ryan
and uh some fun interviews and i hope
that you guys are liking it doing my
damnedest i hope i thank you for
listening to the show and spending your
hour with us yeah you know and gaitin
was great too
this is a good one he was great talking
about an open person he just really i
thought he'd be a little guarded i
thought he'd be in he was mature beyond
his ears oh my god i mean i'm way more
mature than i am i mean this guy he's
not only talented but he's uh it was a
very fun interview and i thank gayton
matarazzo from stranger things and why
don't we just do it let's get inside of
gaten matarazzo it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
what is this background man i love it
this is the tapestry in my room it's a
grateful dead
tapestry hold on a second are you a
grateful dead fan i'm a poser i'm not
that's the thing i want to be very much
so i gotta get into them a little bit
more but i just saw this at this shop in
ocean city and it was trippy and cool
and so i uh yeah so i got it and i
didn't even realize until i got it home
that i had the bears
it is trippy and cool the bears are
around the circle i see them right yeah
too much i can show no no i feel like i
might be on a trip myself okay word that
sounds funny do you know any uh grateful
dead songs
not much dude it's like a one band and i
know i'm a huge
rock and roll fan especially always
especially going back a long time but
grateful dead is one of those where i
just have not read up on who are the old
bands that you like that you think back
i love led zeppelin i uh
i mean i'm not too big on the stones i'm
getting into the stones a little bit but
huge zeppo fan huge beatles fan um jimi
hendrix i'm obsessed with i uh
um i'm also like uh my brother gets me
into a lot of great great stuff
have you listened to any moody blues
not much no nights in white satin
never reaching again
i got yeah i know that i i think you
like the moody blues there's some good
stuff but i like that you're listening
to some zeppelin you got some influence
but you probably
you probably listen to a lot of uh
musicals too huh
you know what i've i wouldn't say i've
grown out of a face i've just grown to
understand that i'm not gonna get by
culturally
slowly listening to show tunes
so i had to branch out a tad what's the
what's the ghost had to learn what's the
go-to show too that's always in your
mind that you always just building one
that never stops
so
it would have been anything from les mis
but then i did it for three years
that's right
and so it was just and then i was like
i gotta move on
right i gotta move on
i gotta get a there was this whole big
uh this stage in my life right after the
show so i i toured with them
for about a year
and
uh
after that i joined the broadway cast
when they revived it in 2014 and was
with that for another year and uh it was
my entire life for a huge big very
formative part of my life my pre-teens
and uh it was for another year maybe two
after that in which it was still every
day in my life i needed to i couldn't it
was just like because it had been so
routine that i sang
from the show every morning in the
shower i reenacted scenes in my bedroom
that i did on the stage
for
for several years because i just wasn't
ready to move on from it to a point in
which it was unhealthy that my brother
sat me down and was like hey
listen
really really it got to the point where
you
it got to the point where you had to
move on like
no literally i had to i had to grow up
from it and uh
i i think i've i've been able to like
it's almost like it was like a tick i've
been able to like quell the need to like
sing it out loud but i still find myself
just like
in my head like like in my dreams
sometimes what's what's the big song les
mis what's the one song that everybody
knows big one everyone knows is one day
more
one day more oh yeah
how does that go
you're making me sick
another destiny i want you to know you
just opened up the floodgates and so now
i'm gonna need like therapy because it's
just
invade my brain for the next three years
and hey we met at uh a con
yeah and i'd seen you at other cons and
you know uh you just you just were a
highlight you just have such a great
energy about you and you just seem like
such a good guy with a good head on your
shoulders i don't know that i would
have a good head on my shoulders at that
age at 19 years old and you starting as
young as you did and having so much
success as you did i think i'd implode i
think my brain would just implode i
don't think i was mature enough i still
don't think i'm mature enough
so i want to i want to go back a little
bit
to like growing up and and and you know
getting involved in all this stuff and
first of all where were you weren't you
driving like a [ __ ] ton today
where were you driving from yeah well
not today today i was good today i uh
well i was in rhode island because i was
at the rhode island comic con how was
that
great it's such a good show it always is
a really really good show were any of
the guys there
the other guys
one of the only guys uh i think i was
the only person from stranger things
there you know what it was it was a
really big con for the uh the cobra kai
group
really
yeah a lot of them were there most of
the most of the principal cast
happen to be at that con there which is
really great they're a great group of
guys that [ __ ] blew up didn't it do you
watch it crazy i i've seen the first two
seasons
i've been not for lack of like wanting
to see the third i just
for some reason like it's hard for me to
like keep up with shows like
when there's a big break between seasons
and stuff which is the same things going
on with mine but um a big break between
seasons and uh anytime it comes out i
just forget to watch
and so but the minute i would start the
minute i started season three i'm just
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
tear it apart yeah so why did you drive
to rhode island comic-con why don't you
fly
well i'm in jersey
and so it was only it was about a five
and a half hour drive that's an ext
that's a stretch it was only probably
about like five hours going up there was
rough but
i like driving better when i can
yeah easier just to put your luggage in
the car
it's true you don't have to deal with
people yes genuinely it's easier to just
just go and honestly my dad starts
driving
for this one before i did so and uh he
he got in the car i could just sleep
so you guys drive together he drives you
well yeah he's with us we'll we'll
alternate up there it's always best when
he when he's ends up being there
sometimes my mom comes my dad's always
better at those shows she'll admit it
herself she's it's not her scene
but uh i had a whole big group coming
with me this time to rhode island really
all your friends
yeah my girlfriend came with me both my
siblings her my sister's roommate her
sister
um
uh my my best friend and my
two of my best friends uh go to school
up in boston
and so they uh they took the trip down
to providence to uh hang out at the con
2 for the day what do they do what do
they do while you're at the con do they
like to experience it with you or do
they kind of f off and do their own
thing
i think initially they were really
excited to see what it was going to be
like with me but the thing is is like
it's not too exciting for people just
hanging out with me to be by the table
because for the majority of the day i'm
sitting at the table signing and taking
pictures for those waiting in the line
so i don't really have time to go and
enjoy the con and at rhode island they
had this big room down on like a night
like it was in a big hockey stadium at
the dunkin donuts center oh wow in
providence and we were on the ice they
had like set up everything
over top of the ice in center of the
arena and set up all the lines and stuff
out there so it was frigid first off but
also it was nowhere near the rest of the
con
so they did they just said they said
[ __ ] this um
i'm going and doing fun stuff they
didn't even stay for the con they went
like out to providence and like my
sister
went to like bars out in providence and
just enjoyed the city but it was great
it was a good time because that night i
was able to go spend time with them so
you don't get offended if they leave
no i completely understand it i wouldn't
want them to stay they'd just be
standing there yeah do you notice how
that always happens when you're filming
people are like i'm so excited i want to
come on the stranger things set and then
they come on and they're like you're
still filming the same [ __ ] scene for
five hours straight literally
that but we never get that i'm never
allowed to bring people on set you're
not
at least i don't think
i've been told that it's super
under wraps no one's allowed on set no
one's there and then sometimes somebody
will have someone on set and it's
confusing because i'm like i thought you
told me i couldn't
but uh
yeah no it's always boring it's it's
just so it's monotonous right for sure
for those who aren't doing it it's great
for me i love doing what i do i love
working on that set but yeah nobody
would want to go and just it's it's a
long day it's like a 13-hour day
doing the same scene over and over again
now that you're over 18 they can keep
you as long as they want can't they long
as they want and they do it
they didn't do it
yeah that's their favorite thing in the
world what now tell me about uh you know
you grew up in where you were not
connecticut
i was born in mystic connecticut mystic
connecticut yeah it's a great little
town a lot of people from the new
england area probably know where it's at
go down there a lot the drawbridge and
the
mystic village all that jazz my mom's
from there my mom's originally from
there but i've lived my i've lived in
new jersey my whole life really yeah my
dad is from there originally my dad's
from here i say there i'm in jersey now
my dad grew up here and uh met my mom
working in connecticut they started
their family there and then and then
packed up and and moved it all down here
when i was only about two months old
always a pretty you seem like you had
come from a pretty happy family is that
is that fair to say
yeah absolutely i think i mean
absolutely as happy as family can
probably be especially i mean my parents
are divorced and so like uh i mean
that's not i love how you went from how
happy they are and then you're like
they're divorced
first off so like that's like
yeah that's not special though no like
at this point who isn't yeah exactly
yeah so they're divorced but like so of
course there's rough patches that's with
every family but right now it's it's
incredible they're both married to
wonderful people
and uh yeah so very very happy family
big family my dad's whole family's down
here so my grandparents all three of my
aunts all three of his sisters and uh
they all have kids so all my cousins and
we're all within like a five mile radius
are you serious so you see your family
constantly constantly
and that's a good thing
oh it's a great thing uh yeah it's a
it's an incredible thing especially
growing up when i was younger it's an
incredible thing
especially because i'm gonna have all my
cousins there like they're in their
siblings of mine yeah
i mean i spend just as much time with
them as i do with my siblings
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon if you don't know magic spoon i
don't know what to tell you other than
listen to this because as a kid
would it be loved more than anything
ryan
in the mornings those breakfast cereals
sometimes at night oh yeah the breakfast
cereals snacks
breakfast cereals and the problem is
they were delicious and the problem
really was that they were filled with
all these ingredients that as you get to
be an adult
yeah they don't help you too much
they're not the healthiest things in the
world would you agree i would agree no
can't process it yeah and cereal growing
up was one of the best things about
being a kid but we had to give it up
because we realized it's full of sugar
and junk
and uh we're all trying to eat better
and that's
that's the concept of magic spoon you
want something delicious you want
something that tastes great and is still
healthy
it's the new year magic spoon is perfect
for meeting your goals whether it's
eating healthier or saving more time in
your morning routine
this is a great product zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving
come on ryan
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free and low carb you can build
your own box available flavors to build
your own custom bundle or cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry cinnamon
cookies and cream maple waffle i mean
these guys have done it right
and uh you know there's nothing better
than opening up a box of cereal and
going i can do this i can do this and uh
boy is magic spoon refreshing go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and start your new year off right and be
sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident
ryan in their product it's backed what
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee so what does that mean ryan
uh if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so why wouldn't you try it why
wouldn't you try something a product
that i love
i know if you're listening you know that
when i tell you something's good for the
most part it's pretty good right
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring my podcast inside
of you is brought to you by helix helix
sleep
uh the most important thing in my world
these days folks is sleep i mean you've
got other things that are important but
if you're not getting a good night's
sleep and you're sleeping almost what a
quarter or more of your life
you're just doing your body and
injustice you're doing your mind and
injustice and you need to sleep on a
quality mattress it's so important i've
had so many surgeries i'm so
uncomfortable most of the time
helix mattresses
really do the trick for me and make me
feel
rejuvenated when i wake up revived when
i wake up and i can really appreciate
that
um helix sleep has a quiz okay even i
pass this it takes two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you i mean why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
ryan you shouldn't
you shouldn't with helix you're getting
a mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium i'm a medium you're a medium
probably a medium too and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot and even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers they've got everything at helix
i took the helix quiz and i was matched
with the uh medium size mattress that's
what's it's like kind of like porridge i
always talk about that it's the medium
that's what i like not too hard not too
soft
uh that's what i like
i love it it's a huge upgrade over what
i i used to have uh not to mention that
brand but uh it's been awesome getting
messages from you guys telling me how
you feel about the product and i really
appreciate that makes me feel good that
we're promoting something here that
people like so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you match to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again yeah and
helix is awesome and you don't need to
take our word for it because it was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine that tells you enough here's
what you need to do just go to
helixsleep.com
inside helix sleep h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com inside take their two-minute
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will
love it helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside that's helix sleep.com inside for
up to 200 off and two free pillows
so did you know at an early age that you
wanted to be a performer i mean
obviously you started very young
sure i don't know if i wanted to be a
performer i certainly was a performer
from a very young age why is that i was
just a riot there was always
that's what my grandfather always used
to say to me goes you're a riot
you're a riot mike exactly exactly no
but i just throughout like the entirety
of uh
my my young years my sister was always
in the music my mom was a was in a
musical theater was a performer when she
was in high school in college and and uh
and traveled with actually like a church
group and went like overseas like went
to like ukraine i didn't even know about
this until like three weeks ago like she
went to ukraine and croatia and sang
like christian music for kids
oh never like a church group i'm like
when's the last time i went to church
you went with like a missionary group to
go perform i didn't know any of this
until really recently so it was in the
it was in the blood early on
when did they know you could sing or you
know or dance when when was that were
you always singing songs throughout you
know throughout the day yeah it's a it's
actually a funny story i was gonna say i
guess i just always had but they i
remember them telling me that um
this is gonna like
make me this is to make me seem so young
which
well you are you're young you're a young
guy it's probably going to make you feel
like super old i'm super old so i'm
already i'm already there i'm already
there my first song i ever learned i was
so i was like one or two years old in
the car where she will be loved by
maroon 5.
i am old
i'm [ __ ] old we're old if you're
listening out there old album it's an
old album at this point it's almost 20
years old 20 years old so you were you
were listening to maroon 5.
songs about jane which is still an
incred i love that album but she will be
loved and just because of the chorus you
know how he goes up on she was she
all that stuff yeah yeah that was my
favorite thing for some reason anytime
you went up during the chorus and so i'd
do it and apparently i just was able to
stay on pitch with them
and they said wow
look at that yeah cause my sister sang
too my sister sang her whole life when
she was younger growing up but yeah that
was the song and then from there i
started going to voice lessons really
young uh with the same future it was all
with my sister
because i just did everything my sister
also did she really wanted to perform
she always wanted to sing she had a
drive and a passion for it and
always wanted to try
and i just wanted to be like my big
sister pretty much really that's where
all the yeah that's where all the
motivation behind it went i don't mind
being what is it
i don't mind spending every day
on the corner
oh it's so good but that was the first
song i ever said
wow so what did did something happen did
your parents do their ears perk up that
they think oh wait a minute we got a
performer here i guess it was just they
just thought it was pretty cute
they're like that's kind of adorable
that they're that their two-year-old was
was singing maroon 5 before i mean
i was i was always singing yourself all
the shows i used to watch too when i was
younger my mom always made sure music
was involved i mean most kid shows have
it but i was always watching barney and
i was always watching the wiggles
and those were all very music heavy
shows and sing along with them sesame
street too so i'd sing along with them
always and so that's where i guess it
started did so my first my first concert
was the wiggles
really
because that used to be a big thing
right the concerts used to be a big
thing oh yeah
uh-huh wow cute i'm talking like
stadium like arena tours the wiggles
would do and would just be packed
it's unbelievable isn't it
six and all of their parents
just singing the songs
choo choo chuck and chuck a big red car
wow
fruit salad yummy yummy come on dude see
i remember i remember [ __ ] like fraggle
rock and uh
let the music play worries for another
day let the music play down at fraggle
rock you don't remember fraggle we had
fraggles were in the 80s
oh no i have no idea you should check
out the fraggles it was kind of twisted
and weird
that's something that i guess i never
really learned much about was like old
like 80s kid like kid stuff like i'm
always like because i've been told like
the biggest thing we get with the show
is did you have to do your homework did
you have to study 80s pop culture music
movies and what's your answer
no
no because i already knew all of it
because my parents i mean they like any
songs they play in the radio they'd be
playing that stuff they'd show me the
movies that they loved when they were
kids like i always compare like people
always ask like they're baffled that we
might have an understanding of what the
80s were like but the people who were in
the 80s they're just they're they love
to talk about the fact that they're from
the 80s already
that's true
they're very proud bunch what movies do
you love from the 80s that you went back
and watched and go wow this holds up
like i'm sure back to the future well
i mean all the classics but that's
everything those are the movies that
like define the generation i want to get
down like the nitty-gritty stuff and
like find like really weird niche movies
that were like i still haven't like i
like of course back to the future
goonies stand by me e.t
uh
i'm trying to think of some other ones i
mean never-ending story that's always
great ah
the neverending story look at the song
yeah but that movie is one of it was one
of my favorite movies
it
forever i don't know why it didn't scare
the crap out of me because i was a very
brightened child
very basic things like the count from
sesame street
still scares me
how can i count the ways don't do it
i have an irrational fear of the count
from sesame really
because i had a nightmare about him when
i was five
what was the nightmare just him creeping
out i remember i remember it like it was
yesterday so i was walking through this
castle dark d it was deep it was
damp it was dark
there was like little torches lining the
walls but for some reason i was with
elmo i was with elmo oh boy we were
walking through this castle and he's
like we got to go in this room now i was
like i don't want to go in that room i
don't know and he was like well there's
no way out of this castle unless you go
through there and so we went in and it
was almost like a little theater with
this with like a curtain where a puppet
show would be like the curtains would
move and then you see the puppets pop up
and then they do like the puppet show
you know what i'm talking about
but but larry was the count just popped
up and he was doing like this weird
spell and he was doing his he was
counting his [ __ ] and stuff what was he
counting
i don't know i was fine it was a
nightmare i had when i was five and he
just he like did like a weird spell and
there was mist and there was fog and
then the animatronic from the
build-a-bear workshops came out of
nowhere and was like chasing god
i'm still scared of that guy now because
of it and seriously it was a recurring
dream for me it could have been like a
week but it also could have been like
two years of my life it's like you know
like stuff like from that far right
like you're very did it is it because
your parents were letting you watch
horror movies at five years old just ran
no the count from sesame street is what
scared me
that's what got me going like that's
what really set set me off
but i do remember however watching jaws
for the first time from my hallway at
like 11 o'clock at night when i was like
four or five not smart no because my
parents were watching it they were doing
their movie night they put us to bed and
they were just gonna chill
uh and they were watching their movie
and they picked jaws and i was like i
had done it a lot because like the past
couple movies they chose to watch were
pretty okay like they i remember they
watched et one night and i just snuck
behind uh in the hallway and just
watched the movie from there where they
couldn't see me but jaws was the movie
of choice and i walk in right as the kid
with the raft
oh boy right as the little boy right
when he dies in the uh
smashed up
uh-huh
remember remember the old woman
he knew
that there was a shark
and you let them swim anyway
why
and then she smacks them i think in the
face oh it's right righteous
i mean well deserved yeah well deserved
smacked roy schneider's face
like the mayor but yeah i remember that
scene like like
no tomorrow dude
it was the worst and i that didn't give
me nightmares i never had a nightmare
about that just about to count you and
elmo trekking through a castle
so annoying dude because it happened so
much to a point in which i just wake up
i'd go to bed be like
all right
i guess we're gonna have to deal with
this dream again
at five years old all right
here we go
so what was the first the first gig you
got the first uh do you remember the
first audition for auditioning what was
that first big audition was for the
lamest tour the first audition you ever
auditioned for was the les mis tour i
didn't get it i did not get it this is
when the tour started it was the 25th
anniversary tour they announced the tour
after the concert that they held i
believe it was at the royal albert hall
in england i'm not sure though like nick
jonas was marius and uh
and the alfie beau who was a very famous
actor a very famous portrayer of jean
valjean
uh he was playing he was in it norm
lewis it was my favorite thing to ever
watch it was it was what got me into
theater was this concert but they
announced the tour the american tour
after that concert and they started
holding auditions i was seven years old
and uh i got a call in for gavrash and i
was so i was like this is it this is my
big break
and i didn't get it and then they called
me were you devastated
i was horrified
really
just genuinely crushed this is before i
was able to really understand that
rejection in auditions was the common
place so you're just a little boy
experiencing it for the first time and
it's something you didn't like were you
thinking of giving up right then
no
i was just like i guess
i'm i must have been but i just wanted
to keep trying and it was like
that show is what kept me
is what kept me going like i was
auditioning for a bunch of stuff a lot
of commercials a lot of theater
a lot of like not a lot of tv and movie
stuff though
it wasn't what i was going for i didn't
have to look for it i still had a lot of
problems with my teeth had a lisp i was
still like
it was it was an awkward stage for me at
the time and tv and film was not about
it i remember
it's just something you didn't think as
a child you knew innately at that young
age that there was something maybe
odd or something that was going to keep
you from doing that stuff so you kind of
ran away from is that what you're saying
i didn't run away from it i i went head
first because i was told first i was
told by my parents that that was always
going to be a possibility at that point
in my life before i had grown up they
didn't know how severely my condition
was going to affect me i didn't know if
i was going to have severe issues with
my back or with my spine with my knees
if it was going to be a real challenge
for me and at that time they really
prepared me for the worse
right and this is called ccd this is the
clado cladocranial dysplasia exactly
that's right thank you
pronunciation thank you um
but uh yeah it was that condition and
they they weren't sure how bad it was
gonna affect me at that point up to that
point it looked like it might have been
getting ready to hit me like a truck
and uh so they were just always prepared
me for that and
i guess this is something that i didn't
realize was messed up until like now at
the time i was like i like that they're
being honest i like that they're
treating me like an adult but at the
time it was not something that a seven
year old should be hearing all the time
but i remember casting directors would
constantly tell me like oh kid we love
you but yeah just get those teeth in
they would they would say that
yeah they say and i i expressed to them
like i was also only seven so a bunch of
seven-year-olds already have their teeth
in so i guess they assumed that it might
have just been like a regular like
missing teeth like teeth situation all
that jazz right right
i always heard him like uh get those
teeth in i'd explain the condition and
then they tell me well you're not gonna
have much luck in this industry then
they would tell you that yeah straight
up
and i don't think i ever told my manager
my mom about this stuff because i
thought that was commonplace like they'd
tell me in the room and i'd be like all
right thank you very much and they'd be
like how was it they'd be like it was
great let's go home
do you think it was because maybe you
were hurt or you didn't want to tell
them that
no or you just didn't
maybe it was something i suppressed but
honestly it was something i was so used
to hearing and dealing with by myself i
heard it so much i knew i was so aware
of it to a point in which i was maybe
numb
to the idea of being offended by it
wow
weirdly weirdly yeah
i get i i think it's helped me more than
it hasn't unless like later down the
road like i'm going to have some weird
anxiety awakening
no like crap i've been suppressing that
but you kept forging ahead you forged
ahead and then what happened
i i forget that because of layman's i'm
like i know they're gonna call me back
because the tour's still going on they
called me back every single time just
waiting for me to get taller that's what
they always said it was like gets hot so
how how often would they call you every
three months
every like three months like six weeks
or three months yeah how tall are you
getting yeah they call me at every
single time and then i do the same thing
over and over again i'd sing the same
song that was a song of my choice i'd
sing the material that they'd send me uh
and then they'd call me in for the
callback i'd go in for the final
callback i was always in for the final
callback like i was always down to the
wire and then it always came back to me
that um
that i was too short
and then the final like i and in the
meantime i was still working i got my
first job on broadway and priscilla
queen of the desert right um which is a
wonderful show it was a great show to be
in at such a young age too
uh
but this i'm still working around this
stuff hoping for les mis above all else
at the same time that this is all going
on so i was i had my broadway debut in
priscilla queen of the desert which is a
great show
very thankful for it it's a it's a
comedy musical a comedy musical it's a
comedy drag jukebox musical because it
was a movie yeah it's a great movie yeah
it's a great movie
and they made a jukebox 70s jukebox
musical out of it wow it was a lot of
fun i got to play the league character's
son who was uh a little bit more of the
of the musical than he was in the movie
and you fell in love you fell in love
with theater oh instantly
that was my passion i remember i go out
the stage door and sign and people would
ask me like are you ever thinking about
doing film one day i said absolutely not
and they said why i said because we have
to get it right the first time
wow
that's pretty how old are you when you
said that eight
i was nine years old nine years old you
gotta get it right the first take
how brilliant is that right was such a
cocky little [ __ ]
oh i remember that was just the worst
were you were you popular in school or
were you uh kind of a nerd group like
you know how
cause i was i was a kind of like an owl
cat and not an outcast but just i didn't
belong anywhere i kind of was the
shortest kid in my school
it's weird it was a weird dynamic
because uh there weren't a lot of
theater kids in elementary school like
most kids don't branch off into the
theater kid world until they get to like
middle school and high school where
there's like like theater programs where
you go and like come do the show and
then like i guess i'll try it and then
they're like oh i love this but if i was
already a theater kid before that was a
thing for kids because i was already
doing it i was in elementary school i
was already going i was listening to
show tunes so like what's that i'm like
it's from a musical like
musical
like well let me tell you that was my
favorite thing but
no i had a great group of friends i had
a well as i say groot i had a great
select number of friends who always had
my back who i never felt judged by
people i went to dance class with
that did not continue by the way did not
continue to answer why is that why it's
that i was terrible at it
it's so bad but isn't it freeing isn't
it just freeing to dance
it was
not it did not feel like that no but
yeah i had a great group of friends who
made me feel accepted but also i didn't
feel like i had time for that i felt not
that i felt like i was above it maybe i
did maybe i mean i was i was
a cocky little [ __ ] at that point but
uh
i i just felt like it wasn't necessary
to worry about it because i was working
at the time for so long
and i would try to explain it to people
they'd be like why you leave school a
little bit early i'm like i'm going to
the city i do a show up there
like why like um
i didn't even think about it myself like
why do you do that like i don't know
it's fun
that's all i thought and i was like it's
a job that's cool i'm like no it's not a
job
i was like yeah they pay me
and they're like yeah but it's not a job
you're nine
you're singing how is that a job
exactly and so i always took great
offense to that i was like it is a job
you don't respect it enough
but it was always good is that i had
friends who were also doing the shows
with me
i had kids who were my age you were
going through the same thing and did you
really love doing the show because there
seems to be this this theme when you're
at a young younger age
and i've talked about this before it
seems like you don't care as much you
just kind of do it you don't get really
nervous you just you know and then the
older you get you start thinking about
[ __ ] it gets in your head and you start
getting nervous at a later age that's
what happened to me but like yeah so you
were kind of a free spirit and didn't
care how old were you when you worked on
your first project i probably you know
in high school uh it was different i
started when i was like 17 like 16 doing
plays and no that's still young i was a
lot more fearless though back then for
sure absolutely and you were fearless
that's the thing is like i didn't
comprehend exactly what i was doing
especially going on a broadway stage
everybody's right there
staring right at you face to face
there's no screen there's no curtain
it's right there and
people kept telling me they're like are
you okay are you okay and i didn't know
what they meant i was like what do you
mean yeah i did this in rehearsal for
three weeks i'm fine i don't know why
like the only difference is that now
there's people there that's the only
difference and i was already so
comfortable with that and i ran they
were nerves of course but i remember
they weren't the nerves that i have now
like back then the nerves were just like
i can't wait i can't wait i can't wait
let's get out there i'm so excited and i
remember like
so we have a guardian uh who works
backstage who's there to like watch the
kids and she's like
works for like uh the union and stuff
the equity union making sure that uh
kids are being uh treated nicely all
that jazz and you have supervised like
you know it's like basically a
babysitter you make sure that like you
uh
go out there and get out together you're
choosing getting costume you're being
treated correctly doing your homework
all that jazz it's a it's a rough job
because
that's the name it was child wranglers
and that's the most and i wish they
didn't change it because that's the most
accurate description of what that means
yeah it was just wrangling this group of
theater kids nine-year-old cedar kids oh
wait there's oh man but i remember i was
like so jazzed that i was about to run
out there before my crew was like give
it a second
wait i was like i just remembered going
and then the minute i was out there
i got a big big cheer which was rare i
got a big big cheer and i didn't know
why i mean it was my broadway debut and
so they put that in the playbill that uh
i was having my broadway debut that
night and then it wasn't until after the
show i heard that the only people
cheering was
the like 100 people that were just there
in my group
to see me in the show that night wow
like there was like so many tickets
were sold that night just from my family
that went out there to go see me in that
show and i knew that and that's why i
could i was not scared i never performed
for them like at the house and they were
like get up and sing for us i'm like no
but that then being there was like the
hug that i needed
did they love you did they think you
were
phenomenal i i don't know
maybe
even if they didn't they were like i was
even if they didn't they were like you
were great you're nine you're like he'll
go get some ice cream and pizza
seriously i just i my grandfather was
absolutely [ __ ] a break
wisely nervous for you he was nervous
for you that's refined for me like all
he would say he wouldn't say it to me he
never said it to me but to everyone he's
like what if he freezes what if he get
it what if he gets out there and he just
freezes
and i just remember him like talking
about this to me like now he's like you
couldn't i could not if he was sweating
like he changed the shirt throughout the
show because he was sweating through it
because if i had like if i did if i like
because any nine-year-old could realize
the scale of what's going on there yeah
and genuinely freeze up
and
i just didn't i didn't feel the need to
did you ever mess up oh all the time but
she didn't care
i did
you did you were hard if i messed up
because then i wasn't doing my job
properly
and i remember the first oh i remember
the first time i ever messed up a line
on stage
i didn't even mess up a line i just
forgot to say a line
and so another actor on stage covered
for me the actor was playing my mom
i remember the line i was like but i
went to stay up late in australian
accents i was like i want to stay up
light if i had an australian accent when
i was nine too i can't do it anymore
but i had an australian accent for the
show and then all she did was like look
at me i didn't say my line and she just
said do you want to stay up late that's
that's exactly how she recovered it for
me really necessary i went back in my
dressing room and i cried for two hours
are you serious i'm not like i cried
till the end of the show
it was already like all my stuff and
finished i had one song i was singing my
song my eyes were puffy from crying like
earlier before that i went home on the
bus ride home i cried the whole way oh
you were so hard on yourself i was just
like i'm like i'm fired my mom's like
you're not fired
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at betterhelp betterhelp
online therapy is uh
somebody a a company that's been with me
for a while now and um
if you listen to the podcast you
understand why they're really helping
people they're helping people like my
friend ryan here ryan you still go to
better help i still go to better help
and how much is it helping you it is
helping immensely yeah a lot of my
friends are like is this was this the
real deal is better help i'm like yeah
man that's a lot of people are using it
and really liking it i get letters
all the time sent to me that say hey
thanks for you know your better help uh
sponsor because they're really helping
me yeah and you know you definitely save
a lot more than going to you know just
getting in your car and going somewhere
um
you know those
therapy sessions are expensive as hell
yeah and better help is definitely a lot
cheaper uh you know many people think
that therapy is for uh
other people
but utilizing therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means you
recognize that all humans have emotions
and we need to learn to understand them
not avoid them
and we've been taught
that taking care of our mental health
shouldn't be a part of everyday life but
that's a huge misconception
we take care of our bodies by exercising
going to the doctor eating well
focusing on and investing in the health
of our minds is just as important
um better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to ryan do you
see them on camera i do you like that i
like it i think it helps for me it helps
for you like to see the person it's more
of a some contact some interaction it
just feels
hey you just see some kind empathetic
faces across from you yeah i like that
no
like i said it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you could be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours look give it a try so many people
have tried this two million people have
been using betterhelp online therapy and
inside of you listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's right 10 percent off
for inside of your listeners off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
inside i like that no
like i said it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you could be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours look give it a try so many people
have tried this two million people have
been using better help online therapy
and inside of you listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com slash inside that's right
10 off for inside of you listeners off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by geico geico asks how would you love a
chance to save some money on insurance
of course you would after all who
doesn't love a great deal right and when
it comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life geico can
help like with insurance for your car
truck motorcycle boat and rv even help
with homeowners condo or renter's
coverage you could save even more with a
special discount when you bundle your
coverages plus add the easy to use geico
mobile app available 24-hour roadside
assistance and more and choosing to
switch to geico becomes an easy choice
switch today and see all the ways you
could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
so
from the kid who was going out signing
autographs saying i never want to do
theater or i never want to do movies
look what we do on one take that you
know they don't do it
then you start to transition what was
the big transition to that and what was
how did that come about stranger things
that was the first thing you really
auditioned for that was like a
tv show or a movie uh well i did one
episode of the blacklist on nbc right
yeah it's great it was a really fun girl
we played uh
this uh brainwashed uh
brainwashed nine-year-old boy who had
been living in a cult
and uh who had been being raised in like
a cult in the woods who had been cast
out so the gist of the episode was
uh they had support there was like this
cult um
the men in the cult which like were
required to take three wives and because
it was a small community there were too
many boys to girls there were more boys
than were than there were girls and so
the marriages in which one man would
have three wives it was not going to
work out because there were enough
people so the gist of the show was this
episode there was a ceremony every year
for the oldest son
of a family once they reached the age of
12 would be celebrated and like this is
like ten like nine ten-year-old kids
they would be like practically like
molested they would be like they would
feast and then they would strip them
naked and throw them out in the woods in
the middle of january
they would die assuming that they were
going to go out in the woods and they
would die and they wouldn't have to
worry about them this is your first
performance on tv
performance so
but yes so they assumed that they would
die out there but what happened was
one of the boys
was able to survive long enough to wait
until the other boys went out and were
cast out and he took them under his wing
continued the practices of the cult out
in the woods collecting all the boys
that were being cast out until they
eventually plotted to go back and kill
all of them
and they were successful in doing so and
it's a cool episode and my character was
a nine-year-old potential suicide bomber
who drove a van out onto the freeway
full of explosives
with the button ready to go saying the
only cure for corruption is disruption
over and over and over again
and that's like it was dirty it was like
covered in grime and it was like a
hostage negotiation like if i if i hit
the button everybody on the highway was
going to be born in the smithereens and
so
this really nice lady like
one of the lead characters in the show
talked me out of it reunited me with my
mom and the information i gave them gave
them enough to go and infiltrate the
cult and stuff like that and you're
then your parents allowed you to do this
oh great it was awesome because all i
said was that one line over and over
again i had to play a crazy kid it was
awesome wow that was the only tv
experience i had before doing stranger
things and what was the stranger things
audition like what do you i mean did you
even like
your agent just said you said hey
there's this show that they're doing
stranger things or how had that come
about um it was such a random basic
audition
just a random basic audition it wasn't
special there's this thing stranger
things and they want you to audition for
it it wasn't called stranger things it
was called montauk
it was a show that was called montauk it
was going to take place on montauk long
island that was always the goal it was
based off of a real place called camp
hero right
yeah it was this uh this government
facility that was uh supposedly it was
uh like a a radio tower type thing it
was like her like communications and
radio communications for the military
and there were rumors that there were a
lot of weird shady government
experiments going on and so they base
their show off of that
and it's the same thing hawkins lab is
just based off of camp hero and isn't
camp hero still there
yeah it is
you can go see it you're not allowed in
but you can go up to it and people have
gone underground and have seen and heard
some weird weird [ __ ]
really
yeah like animal carcasses
scattered around the like edge of the
facility but to like a
like alarming extent
like tens dozens and dozens of like
animals just like all scattered around
the like premises
this is creepy [ __ ] i don't know like
chasms that are full of water at this
point everything's flooded out it's on
montauk so anytime something flooded
they didn't go in there to clean it out
because it was an abandoned building so
it's waist-high water people go in and
like try and find the facility and see
what's in there but
like rumors of strange noises rumors of
uh
like
buildings being like like rooms being
uncovered that like had like like chairs
with like straps on them why would they
have chairs so it's no wonder why they
they made this series based loosely on
this kind of thing it just makes sense
yeah i took the i took the job thinking
it was gonna film in long island a three
hour from my house
uh it was gonna be a mini series i was
gonna be in like three or four episodes
and uh then they i i signed on and they
were like so change of plans it's gonna
film in north carolina and then a month
later they're like change the plans it's
gonna film in atlanta georgia and it's
not montauk anymore it's called stranger
things i was like that's cool cool name
but why'd you change it and it turns out
there was this whole like
lawsuit thing that went down like it
even resurfaced after the show i think
the same guy or a different guy tried to
come forward saying that his idea was
stolen for the show even though like it
was based on historical events which is
something
in my life but there was already a book
series called the montauk project that
was based
on
the potential government experiments
done at camp hero and so they weren't
allowed to use that because of licensing
purposes wow i bet nobody who's
listening knew that i sure as hell
didn't know that i get i mean i might be
like
i i don't know that's the reason
that was definitely a factor in why they
changed it i think
for sure there's some mythology there
yeah really it's like it's like it's
loosely rooted in some like real stuff
but of course
all the upside down like like the the
extent in which uh it goes is um
like the the experiments going on in the
lab nothing about like the other
dimensions and the upside down that's
all that's all about i'm ready do you
think were you confident in the audition
did you know your lines inside out did
you no
no
come on
i know it's one of the only auditions in
which i i had two other ones that week i
was like razzle my mom wakes me up that
morning she's like you ready for this
tape we gotta go over the city i'm like
oh my god i completely forgot about this
one and so i'm memorizing my lines as
i'm going up to the city i have nothing
i know none of it
i'm freaking out but also i was like ah
i had two this week
i'm like this this one i mean maybe
it'll be fine i'll be good i go up there
i have the sides in my hand which i
always hated doing
and i was literally looking down at the
sides as i was forgetting lines you can
see the audition they released the
audition tapes of all the kids
for like their first tape and you can
see me looking down at my sides because
they don't know i don't know my lines
i have no idea why they but like they
told me to like the minute you sent that
tape i mean we needed you in the show i
was like that's the dumbest thing i've
ever heard in my entire life it was one
of the worst auditions i've ever isn't
that something that it's just
it's just you it's just your personality
it's something about you that they just
gravitate towards when i say you it's
like the proverbial you it's like
me or or that guy or when they walk in
that's the guy i'm like but that guy
didn't give a good or it doesn't matter
that's the guy
it was weird it was what was your worst
audition do you remember oh i auditioned
for this thing called the gray with liam
neeson
and and uh the gray i think it was
called or the gray wolf or whatever it
was called but uh
i remember the guy who cast that cast me
in a couple of movies like pool hall
junkies and like uh cast me in urban
legend and some other stuff and i went
in there
i was so bad that i stopped myself and i
said
i said
i'm terrible
and he goes no no no it's fine i go nope
nope i got i gotta go i go john jon paps
to dare a great casting director i say
oh great yeah i gotta go home i gotta go
home man i gotta i gotta
work on this this is terrible
i didn't work on it
and he goes hey man rosie i love you go
on
and i left
but i was i was dreadful i couldn't go
on it was just like it wasn't reading it
was it wasn't like glancing at your
lines it was this it was like
it was it was it was just me going uh
blah blah blah blah blah and occasional
eye contact
just no eye contact just me reading the
lines i had like it was it was it was a
terrible audition it happens oh so
what'd they do did you even get a call
back or did i got a call back that i was
hella prepared for
i got a call back i was like
i ain't doing i am messing this up again
i got a call back for this one they
wanted me back and so i was like all
right i'm putting in everything i got
for this one it was so funny because i
was auditioning for mike originally i
think all the kids i don't know if you
heard that my whole stomach just went
i didn't hear it oh god in the mic oh i
hope it's in the cut i hope it is too
me too i'll raise the volume on it it
was literally it was like an internal
fart like you didn't let a guard out and
it just went back up
by the way can you armpit fart
no oh i'm a genius with that i'm a
genius
[Music]
there you go what brother can leg fart
oh i could look far too but they're not
as long they're like yeah
yeah no it's a little like like squirts
yeah do you know that people are
listening right now saying gayton is way
more mature than rosenbaum
rose and mom's armpit farting
and he's interviewing interviewing a 19
year old
he's been upstaged completely oh yeah
i wish i could uh what what was i
talking about you were saying you got
the call back and you were hella
prepared and you just you killed it
uh no i didn't say i killed it i was
prepared though
right it was fun i was auditioning for
mike originally right that was um
[Music]
most kids were i think probably at that
point it was either micro wheel dustin
really hadn't been written all that much
the whole like uh
i remember in the dummy sides lucas his
big shtick was that he was like
obsessed with going out with nancy
like mike's older sister right i
remember like that either it was dustin
or lucas but i remember uh like lucas
had this biggest crush on nancy and that
was like the driving force behind the
dummy size i know they never really
wanted to go with it but they just
needed like audition material right and
uh i remember after i went in for the
callback that i was up for mike or lucas
or dustin or it was like some weird like
lost in translation like type stuff but
for some reason i thought that i was
going in for lucas
really
i had the sides before lucas they did
the scene from stan by me
where um corey feldman's character he's
i'm gonna rip your head off and [ __ ]
down your neck he's at them he's at the
fence and he's screaming at the guy uh
in the junkyard that was the lucas
science that they picked
and uh we did that scene and i was uh
yeah i was so
ready to play that part i'm like he's
he's
he's serious and he's he's got an edge
to him and he's he's committed and he's
like rudely he's like really cool tough
guy character and uh
and then they call me back and you're
like no no no um
sorry
we want you for dustin and like i
remember we were like pissed about it
we were like oh man
really we thought we didn't think it was
a big part we heard it was a seri we
thought it was like a recurring guest
character
uh that he wasn't going to be in much
that he was a pretty fun character to
play but wasn't like pivotal to the
story or anything you're like no yeah
you're coming in for dustin so then they
had the final callback
how do you read for dustin in l.a after
they did you meet with other actors did
you mix and match
a little like a very small amount this
happened in l.a right i was only by
myself for the first for the first two
uh auditions i remember
and um
i went to la
and i met finn and we were in the same
we were in the room together we were in
like the waiting room and his leg is
bouncing and i'm biting my nails and
but the thing is especially when you're
younger
we might have been going over the same
part we weren't but like we could have
been
and i just remember
he talks about it a lot like i remember
i walked in i was like hi and you just
look at he's like hey
and i was like what's your name and it
just started from there like we just
started talking and laughing and i was
like you're from canada that's crazy
i thought it was the craziest thing in
the [ __ ] world and he was from canada
i'm like oh this is a real project
they're flying people in from out of the
country he's from vancouver
two hour flight from l.a
this is awesome this is legit
but
i just remember it was an immediate
connection with him and we established a
rapport there right before they called
us in for um
the audition in in that room and i
remember
it went really really great because we
were in there we talked with them for a
bit just like about kid [ __ ] kind of
video games or movies or music
finn was always such a big movie buff it
was always into the classics it was
always like asking like what camera they
were using to film the audition
oh my gosh really
always has been and still is is still so
like that's what i love watching finn on
set because he's always so
invested in everything that's going
around not just in what he's doing which
is always incredible but of like how the
set is running and like what the
directors are doing
what the dps are doing what cameras they
have that year
i know so much of like camera lingo
solely because of talking with finn
so he's really interested he's probably
going to be a writer director when he
gets older he's going to be an
absolutely incredible director
you could just tell i just know
because he's aware a lot of actors
aren't aware when they're on set like
you said he's aware of all the things
that are going on i remember when i was
on set
just
every day i was like you know i could
come here and i could just learn my
lines and hit my mark and do my job or i
could pay attention and learn and learn
about this craft and learn about all the
things that go on in filmmaking and it
was like a crash course it was like yeah
you know just years and years of
learning uh how it works just by being
on set and paying attention
he's always been very aware of that he's
always been very aware of going in and
understanding this is not just something
where i can expand my
ability on the camera which is already
exceptional
which he's already just just great
but he goes in understanding that this
is an incredible learning experience an
incredible opportunity to know so much
more than you might have potentially
known when going in to direct your first
project yeah when you shoot your first
project yeah when you hey when you first
saw stranger things because like there's
one thing you get on set you get cast
you're like holy [ __ ] this is great i'm
doing it you're acting
when you first saw it though
when you first saw the first episode of
stranger things
what was that experience like because
the crit yeah
i just love this i love this we watched
all of us all the kids it was
me finn caleb million noah it was before
sadie joined the cast she didn't join
until season two which sucks
like it's incredible it's like as if
she's always been there from from day
one but all i can think is like oh my
god it would have been so great if the
if the gang was complete for that first
initial
go for it
but uh because it didn't it always felt
great but it didn't feel complete
it didn't feel complete until we until
uh until sadie joined it i was like cool
this is our group this is the group
that's what we needed that's always
that's always what it felt like to me
but anyway we were uh we went into this
on stage at screen gems in uh
in georgia we uh it was this back little
room oh somebody's screaming downstairs
i don't know what that is
like
probably a dog or something um
there's this back room
where um
they now hold all the costumes for the
uh for background actors
all the costumes in the in in the back
that are gonna be like trying on for
like
for all the background work and stuff so
it's really cool but back it was an
empty little space empty little room
and uh they brought this rinky dink
little tv out there with a like a bird
like with like just a regular
dvd and a dvd player that had a rough
cut of the first episode of the show
right a lot of the editing hadn't been
finished at all right
a lot it was still there were still like
shots in which you could still see the
green screen it wasn't even edited out
stuff like that but they had music put
together a rough cut of the music they
had it was just a rough draft of what
the show was going to look like but even
they put so much work into that and all
of us were in it all the cast
the crew everybody was there on that day
which grants it was pretty small at the
time
and we just sat down and we we watched
it and i just still remember every
single moment of it to this day
six years ago blown away
six years ago at this point absolutely
blown away
just like this is something that like
we've contributed to that's what was so
great being so young at the time it was
just going to school and filming and
going to school and filming all at the
same time every single day it was
routine we were spending so much time
with each other the same kids every
single day so of course we fought and of
course we were
oh man someone's laughing
i'm gonna hear it i don't hear it you
don't even hear it i don't know i think
it's my stepmom whatever
i don't even know but um yeah we like so
we like fight every now and again and it
was getting to a point in which like we
were all ready was like we've been doing
this for like seven months
let's wrap this [ __ ]
let's go home like it was like because
we hadn't seen it we hadn't seen what we
were doing right we've been doing it and
we hadn't gotten any bit of like
assurance that this was going to be
great we kept getting told enjoy while
it lasts because it's probably not going
to get a season two
and uh
we just watched it and just
knew we were like
okay we're in good hands we're safe
this is worthwhile
hey this is called uh
[ __ ] talking with gayton oh i love it
these are my patrons my lovable patrons
who give back a little more to the
podcast amazing
yeah they're amazing and they they love
you and there's some questions and just
rapid fire
great little lisa love dustin and
steve's friendship what's your favorite
scene between you and joe carey
uh train tracks season two farrah
fawcett hairspray scene where he tells
me what his secret to his hair is
because it's the one scene in which two
characters the first scene i think in
the show where two characters who have
nothing in common
finally find something in common with
each other and
realize themselves how arrogant they
were being they didn't like each other
at all solely because of the superficial
idea of hanging out with the nerd and
also hanging out with the jock
and then they have something in common
and it brings them together in a way
that they never thought it would and it
was like a beautiful budding little
flower of something very very fun i love
it rozzy when you sang the neverending
story theme song did you see the movie
before that i know you did
indeed indeed i did did you know all the
words to it already no i didn't remember
the song
what are the first words to the song
what how's it go again
turn around
ryan
ryan's right here and ryan has not
missed one episode he's my engineer you
can't see him say hello ryan
hey what's up
how you doing i'm good man this is great
yeah he
loves it he loves you he loves the uh
the show and uh i mean who doesn't love
the show uh
so you you had seen the movie that was
your answer of course you had seen the
movie before you sang it uh how much and
you recorded it in the studio right you
recorded the song in the studio you
recorded the song no we sang it live
sang it live to a track or
no i think it was acapella
did you have time to learn it how long
did you have to learn that
so it was super quick so gabby to play
susie she's incredible she's one of my
favorite people to ever exist and i hope
she hears me say that um she's the best
seriously and she's a broadway kid as
well she was uh in a very great show
called fun home an incredible role in an
incredible show called fun home
genius musical incredible uh but and he
goes so she sings
and being our extra little theater [ __ ]
as like we we made a number out of this
we knew what we needed to sing we
weren't gonna sing harmonies or anything
and then we were doing it and i forget
if i had the harmony tracker she did but
i think we're like one of us want to
take the harmony track we're like yeah
i'm like lower or higher you look lower
like all right and so we just did it and
then we made a whole number out of this
thing we show up on set to do her side
first in her bedroom
where she's singing the song and i was
off camera reading for her
and singing the song with her
and um
and they were like guys
it's great
they're like this is a literal number
like
i remember like
in this you haven't done broadway shows
so you have to you have
oh my god
and that's where the prep was like she
had the hard work because she they
filmed her stuff first right and then
they filmed all of my stuff later that
night when the sun went down out on a
random field and hill right on the lot
and they put blue screens up around the
parking lot area so you couldn't see it
and we were like sitting up on like the
grass and she was standing there too and
she sang with me on my end i don't know
if there was a track i don't think there
was i think we just kept acapella and
just made sure we remembered the tempo
it was great all right even if you're
recording for them for the album that's
that's just our live recording from the
show
it sounds great
kelly s rapid fire here we go how is it
working with robert england in the new
season of stranger things oh robert's
great
he is great i did urban legend with him
and he's just
very very cool he's an icon he's an icon
very very cool robert's great the fact
that we got him is awesome
uh michelle k any pranks from behind the
scenes of stranger things and who's
responsible for those yeah i remember
there was this one prank it's not my
prank uh it's
is it funny now i don't know if it's
funny now it might be less funny now
it's pretty messed up but i remember
there was a there was one of our crew
members who worked in costumes she was
getting married very very soon this
might be season one or two and um
she's so excited of course she's about
to be married it's incredible and uh
noah and millie decided to prank call
her and uh prank called noah prank
called her as the
brian
the uh manager of the venue that her
wedding was telling her that there was a
construction issue at the venue and they
were going to have to cancel their
reservation or her wedding this is like
two weeks out of her wedding so she's
freaking out she's crying
she's freaking out i mean if you're
going to prank someone you got to prank
other people in the cast you can't
believe the god this is no literally
listen and they remember like so noah
can't see it he's just on the phone on
one end and really is the room and she
usually goes and she's like
and i'm just like i don't know i think i
think she took it well i think
afterwards you took it well maybe not
for like the first day or two oh my gosh
now you think it well but i remember
that and i was like
whoa
so maybe no more pranks on set
uh maya p what are the best and worst
things good question best and worst
things about growing up in the public
eye
uh best thing is that i i now i think i
have uh a general awareness of what
should be pretty acceptable behavior for
somebody my age you know what i mean
like
it's an age where you can make mistakes
and should make mistakes but at least i
have a bit of consciousness as to
knowing that my actions are going to
affect other people everybody this is
the case for everybody but in my case
it's pretty immediate
if i were to do something it would
definitely affect those and everybody
would know about it yeah so it's
definitely keeps me grounded but worst
part there's a lack of anonymity there's
a lack of a little bit of fun there i
think especially being
really young you want to be able to do
dumb stupid teenage [ __ ]
and uh
deal with it by having your parents
ground you rather than have to deal with
it with people making a headline that
you're
just like washed up or something i feel
like that with cell phones and [ __ ] too
just like in general it's like we don't
we didn't i didn't grow up with cell
phones so we were able to just do what
we wanted and nobody could see and you
know nowadays everybody's got a phone so
if i'm gonna get up there and act like a
jackass everybody's gonna know about it
everybody can just record it and i am a
jackass i am a jackass it was just
stories like back then you just hear
it's like i remember i was at a bar and
like i don't know who
like
rob lowe was there he was trash or
whatever like i don't know right right
no it's like you'll know that's true we
have a video of it
um hey you know i saw in an interview
that you know talking about anonymity
but something cool is that is it true
that a bunch of your family and friends
started to work at a restaurant and then
you
were you got a job at the restaurant
while filming stranger things and you
did it tell us why you did because i
know you were playing the story is like
you were playing mario kart yeah and
they were all interview yeah yeah so in
the fallout interview but i loved it
because they were off to you know
working and you were just by yourself
playing mario kart over and over and
over to the point where you mastered
mario kart yeah
i'm so good at mario kart
i'm so good at mario kart and nobody
plays mario kart anymore like it's not
like it's like a popular game it's not
like smash brothers
right like everybody like who's mine's
like is really good at like smackdown
this is like tournaments we have in
school but i was always really good at
mario kart but no it was just this
restaurant that was uh nearby where i
lived and a lot of my friends happened
to work there i was attended the
restaurant quite frequently because my
friends worked there and this was during
this was during the pandemic and it was
an outdoor seating restaurant so it was
open and um
it was the only thing that i saw that
was gonna make me not sit on my ass all
summer because from at that point from
march up until june
i was
i was quarantined i was inside it was
like during the whole it was during the
z social distancing do not leave your
house phase like before anybody was
getting back into work before anybody
doing anything what are you getting paid
at this restaurant
it was i was getting a food runner so
what like 7 25 7 25 an hour and you're
you're
and you're bringing food you're bringing
food to tables right you got a mask on
yeah so i had like a like you know the
pullover sleeve mess yep
yeah i one of those and a cap i still
have long hair at this point so i tucked
in all the hair into my hat and covered
it and put the sleeve over the mask so
the only thing that you saw was my eyes
and i double mask so i had a mask
underneath i had like a regular like
surge like two surgical masks underneath
and then the sleeve mask on top because
i still want to be cautious about it i
was like i'm not like i come from a
really really uh
uh small town in jersey super super
conservative but and super like at this
point
really really uh
i guess lacks is the nicest word i can
say about the situation going on but
super anti-vaxx area yeah so even back
then they were like like any time there
was a restaurant that was open people
would just go just to make a point of it
like i'm not socially distancing i'm
going to be cool oh yeah
but i didn't like to feed into that so i
made sure that i was still very cautious
about it right so i really did mask up
and it helped disguise me a little bit
but did they still recognize you just
from the eyes 100
people have told me that they said like
they're like i saw you i was like cool
and like it was the eyes i'm like i'm
gonna go
cry in the bathroom and i feel weirdly
attacked and violated with that dude i
saw you imagine any person it could be
my brother it could be my girlfriend and
like it's just the eyes and like you
walked up and like i know it's you i
just recognize your eyes like that's
crazy this is scary i've never met you
in my life
scariest thing anyone's ever said to me
hey do you think this is the uh do you
think this could be the last season of
stranger things that they told you
anything or do you think it could be
you're hoping it's not
it would be dumb if it was
it would be dumb if it was the last
season it's probably it's for like
they're not they can't say whether or
not there's gonna be a five until season
four is released
right and then they'll know based on
ratings based on how it does if they're
gonna want to five
it's gonna do well
like even if it's not like even if it's
not a good season i think it is even if
it's not a good season it's still going
to do well because people have been
waiting for it for so much so long and
our fan base is just incredible are you
excited are you excited about the next
season
oh yeah
oh my gosh you love being on set you
love being on set you love acting with
these guys i didn't realize how much i
took it for granted until season four
though because of covet and everything
we started production march i think
march 8th or something and then closed
down march 16th we had like like a week
of filming before it shut down for a two
week hiatus which ended up being six
months
and um
it was it was we were devastated but it
was we got back in september and i was
like oh my gosh this almost got like
taken away for good
and before at the time which i was just
like oh back to another season
and that's what i took i was like not
only was i taking it for granted the
experience but i was taking the the
learning experience and the job and the
love of the crafts i wasn't taking it
seriously
as much as i could have and so that i
think this season is the one where like
a lot of us maybe but i just felt like
it's really where i genuinely tried
every single day every time i walked in
i was like this is gonna be a good day
because i'm gonna make it one that's
great it felt really great and that's
why i'm really stoked for the season i
feel like everybody was just putting
every bit of their heart and soul into
it because
maybe that was
it was clear to us that that might not
have been
normal anymore or commonplace right is
there lastly are there any like little
love connections on set has there ever
been any
are there anything like people dating or
people flirting or people are you guys
just keep that to yourself
not for me i mean i've been in a
wonderful relationship with my
girlfriend for almost four years
yeah it's great she's incredible you've
been in a longer relationship than me
and you're 19.
that's amazing but on set other people
there might
there might be something
i don't know i mean and if it's true and
nobody tells me i mean charlie and
natalya have been dating for probably
like four or five years at this point
wow
yeah i think they've been seeing each
other since season one but we're pretty
private about it until uh
until like maybe a little bit after it's
hard to hide it like they couldn't go
out and like be like go on dates in
public without people being like oh
jonathan in this you're really dating
like like the headlines about it so
eventually it was hard to keep it secret
i think but they've been together for
quite some time how cool is winona ryder
we noticed thebomb.com genuinely one of
the sweetest ladies i've ever gotten to
know really he's great
just a sweetheart he's really genuinely
she's great
and and you know david hart harbor
yeah david harper he just seems like the
coolest guy he just seems like he's
awesome i love working with david
there's never been a person who
who drives me to impress as much as
david does really work around a group of
people sean levy too who's uh who
directs uh episodes three and four of
all of our seasons and is an executive
producer on our show uh he he he i mean
what have you known that he's uh
directed um do you see the movie free
guy that came out with i didn't see that
you directed that
he directed night at the museum oh yeah
but he's he's been working for so long
he has such an energy and a drive but
like he just drives me to just always
feel like i'm like i really want to
impress this person i want to like not
impress but say more like this person
drives me to be the best version of
myself on the set that i can because
they take what they do so seriously like
david as well like david
is
always just so into it and ready and
committed and understands
everything he needs to do i mean maybe
he doesn't feel the same way but
whenever i see it i just know like it
just looks like he's always giving us
all as is ready to do the best he can no
matter what he's doing
it's not intimidating it's just like
all right let's do it yeah do you do you
want to continue doing movies and tv and
stage and just do all of it are you do
you want to get back to the theater or
what are you excited about back in the
theater i really want to get back into
the theater because i haven't done the
theater i haven't really like done a
long run uh in a show
it doesn't have to be on broadway i love
to do work off-broadway i'd love to do
workshops either i'd love to do
experimental theater
um
but i've never done a long run since my
voice changed
right
it's been a bit
well you're getting older this is good
exactly i'm real i'm excited to try out
new things and also uh now would be the
first time i do a show in which there's
no child labor laws that are gonna be
like uh
there's no like child wranglers
no child wranglers no dial wranglers
those wranglers are gone those days are
old uh this has been a a real treat for
me i i you know i met yeta khan and i
was like this dude is just so cool i
think he'd be a great guest and i was
right about it you were you were a
fantastic guest today i mean i think
people are going to love this
i'm just glad i got to be a part of it
thank you for having me on yeah this is
just wonderful i really really enjoyed
it i wish you continued success you're a
great guy and uh i'll see you at the
next con or i'll see you somewhere i'll
text you and say hello do it no
seriously i'm doing a lot of the cons uh
i'm getting back into them now that uh
they're they're open after uh
restrictions are listed from the
pandemic and stuff so i'll see you very
very soon i know yes indeed all right
give my love to the family downstairs
screaming go listen to some grateful
dead some moody blues
and now i will all right
now people know i'm opposing
all right thanks so much man thank you
so much michael see you brother bye
uh there you go gate and matarazzo i
hope you had a lot of fun with it again
if you really enjoyed the interview
please subscribe to the podcast listen
to it spread the word with your friends
and follow us on our handles ryan what
are those at inside of your pod on
twitter inside of your podcast on
instagram and facebook that is correct
uh we appreciate you listening and and
hopefully you got something from it
hopefully you're like hey you know that
didn't suck
um thank you for spending the day with
us you're an hour it's just an hour but
again there's so many podcasts out there
so it's like you know you just hope that
people tune in and they continue to tune
in that's all you can do is do your best
you know what was cool
was hearing judd apatow say how he
listens to the podcast
and he was like oh your jimmy connors
episode and the kevin nealon episode i'm
like oh my god you listen to the podcast
that made me really happy i was like oh
somebody i really respect and adore
so that was pretty cool uh if you want
any inside of you on uh any inside of
you merch or smallville merch signed go
to the inside of you online store
there's small of the lunchboxes there's
uh autographed autographed pictures of
me of lex of inside of you mugs of
tumblers there's so many really cool
things there also go to sunspin.com
and get tickets to see my band sunspin
uh march 5th at 2 p.m and 6 p.m two
shows
um you know you you can win zooms
there's the prizes there's all sorts of
stuff you can also go to stageit.com and
type in sun spin but p please join us i
think you'll have a great time everybody
who comes to the show is surprised about
uh by how much fun they have they
actually enjoy
themselves and we respond we see your
messages on the screen and we're like oh
look it's
tr467 what's up man thanks for being
here and uh all that stuff
and you can go to sunspin.com if you
want to buy any get any zooms with me
um i'm on cameo
patreon if you want to join patreon the
lovely patreon it's patreon.com inside
of you uh if you know my patreon saves
the show the patrons they what would i
do without the patrons you get you know
they get to ask questions to the guests
they get those different tiers so check
it out if you want to support the
podcast good questions patrons just by
the way
really they really had like last few
like this last week we did a few
interviews and yeah dude they're really
coming in hot they really know their
stuff in fact sometimes i use their
questions as part of my questions before
i read their questions we just have to
credit them now i have to credit them
they're very smart very intuitive very
knowledgeable and they do their homework
they do you know and so that's nice so
thank you for listening to the podcast i
really appreciate it right now one of
the uh perks of being a top tier um
patron p-a-t-r-o-n
is that you get your name read off and
these are supporters these are the top
supporters of the podcast i'm going to
read them off
i think ryan knows most of them
let's see nancy d leah yes sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h nico p
robert
robert b correct jason
w kristen k amelia oh alison l raj c
joshua d c j p jennifer and stacy l jen
r
n
p s s jamal
f
janelle p
correct that's what i said roger s
kimberly e mike e eldon supremo 99
ra mira santiago m chad
d w correct leanne p janine r maya p
matty s belinda and chris h dave age
spider-man chase sheila g
brad
t rey
h correct tabitha t
what happened the tap of the 262 273 273
not to be confused she's no longer with
us but 272 shout out to her all right uh
tom and lillian a michelle k talia m
betsy d chad l rochelle marion meg k dan
and angel m rhiannon
[Music]
c corey k super
uh sam
coleman g dev nixon michelle a jeremy c
cody r gav vanader correct david c john
b brandy d uh
for camille s the c correct joey
pants joey m willie f christina e
adelaide n omar i lena n eugene and leah
chris p nikki g
corey patricia heather l jake b bobbitt
eddie
abol f
okay f joshua b tony g shawn r and megan
t
these are the top tiers these are the
people that give back the patrons that
really give back to the show and keep us
afloat and i i couldn't do the show
without them so thank you for all your
support and love
and um
we just keep doing this i think we're
over we're over 200 episodes now i hope
to do 200 more and that's up to you so
if you're listening continue to listen
and get other people to listen to it um
from myself michael rosenbaum in the
hollywood hills of california ryan is
from the hollywood hills of california a
little way to the camera
we love you guys thank you for allowing
me to be inside of each and every one of
you and you know what just be good
yourselves be good to yourselves thanks
for listening
and uh be grateful man we're all here
we're alive let's uh let's keep that
going
i'll talk to you
[Music]